one video shows protesters on the
boulevard you will see some are obeying
the law and mainly staying on the
sidewalk as they walk down las vegas
strip at various points however
protesters spill into the middle of the
street one protester waving a black flag
approaches one of our officers on a
motorcycle encircles him with the flag
appearing to taunt the officer this
individual has seen several times
throughout the evening agitating police
at one point he threw his body in front
of a police car laying down in front of
it so at this point I want to show you a
sequence of videos and then we'll have
commentary subsequent to video this is
not a comprehensive catalog of the
videos this is a Justice snippets that
we are able to obtain in the early
throes of the investigation there is
obviously you can imagine the number of
body cameras we still need to go through
and internet video to be obtained
that officer was attempting to block the
intersection for pedestrian safety when
he was approached by that individual
the majority of those vehicles are not
associated with the protests people
attempting to get go about their
business
notice the red shirts
once again notice the red shirts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this one is approximately three minutes
so bear with us as we go through it and
you'll understand as we get near the end
the reason why
[Music]
[Music]
and for clarification the officer
interacting with this young lady is a
North Las Vegas PD officer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]